citizens of the reject Nation we are
back to continue Black Mirror season 6
episode 2 log Henry Greg how are you
feeling sir I'm doing great John I see
there's a Scottish town in here that's
right we're gonna do this for the entire
radio so leave a like for bad Scottish
accents and also while you're at it
subscribe hit that notification yours
was good yours is the best and you know
what else is the best is when you guys
check out that bat verse t-shirt over in
the shopzeroedition.com store it is the
Crown Jewel of the t-shirts that you
have designed I would say sir and also
what's awesome is when you guys come
over to the patreon.com the real reject
sync up with your own copy of Black
Mirror and enjoy The Full Experience
everything that doesn't make the
Highlight Reel sync up with your own
copy it's a lot of fun over there got a
bunch of other shows and movies we cover
as well and without further Ado let's
jump into the look
get in my Bella
[Music]
I was worried it's almost six I took a
detour after last to show Pierre the
pretty way I slept through it an
American
nice to meet you you too Janet pretty we
think you've captured mum whoa whoa
that's racist
do you grow up in America or are you
originally Jesus mum U.S born and bred
you are prying mom with these General
getting to know you questions we'll
probably set off Monday morning you're
only staying two nights we've got to
head on to run to shoot uh my film a
film oh here we go so that's what your
documentary is about this egg collector
from drums he's not a collector he's
guards Red X against collectors who want
to steal them it's a it's a big trade
that sounds awesome this is going to be
a story about one of the last remaining
holdouts against the commodification of
nature wow
voter man who watches eggs
also that
does that thing work
nice
no tape boo what are you gonna film with
it
I didn't know we were watching the idol
good to go what's Burger rack
uh old detective show your folks were
seriously into it they love cops mum had
a crush on John Nails she used to say I
had a nice bum I do not want to think
about your mom getting over some did
spot well he did have a nice one yes he
did I told you never show your face in
here again hello Stuart hey
well I guess
you're gonna tell me your pronouns oh
God
he was on my film course as well oh he
thinks so good he name after him someday
Oh I thought they were gonna name it
after me so yes well that would be the
smart movie diversity and all that oh
geez oh God killing it my man you're
still in business I keep telling Dad if
things don't pick up we just have to
bite the bullet and jack it
hey Sean Hannah is he depressed of
course he's depressed there used to be
three pubs around here and that'll be
the last man standing it's a proper Dead
Zone because of world culture that's
right it's because of pronouns Ian Adair
was the guy he lived up at five Acres
Farm on the hill there with his mom and
dad now people said he was quiet easily
LED not too bright all of that no but
really he was just some local guy he
turned out he tortured and killed people
wow I've got your storytelling Instinct
you tell it
what ended with your dad can I just
start from the beginning
then in 1997 this couple in their 20s
had a cottage for their honeymoon I call
me still had tourists like how this
feels like a dramatic reenactment
Unsolved Mysteries they were here for
about a week loads of people saw them
the cleaner comes to get their Cottage
ready for the next booking their cars
parked outside and all this stuff's
still there no
after a day or two becomes a big story
tabloids pick it up places swarming with
journalists it's a frenzy is this the
small town Scottish murder from the last
episode
in here he's had way more than usual
he's making a nuisance of himself ah
there's a poster of the missing couple
on the wall he even makes comments about
the girl and your dad yeah he tells you
in his bath says he's got half a million
to come back and shoot the place up yep
and he's got a shotgun dad asks Kenneth
going to check in on Ian you don't have
a one person so then Dad says yeah of
course it's my dad
on the door
Ian doesn't answer dad's walking back to
his car when Ian opens the upstairs
window whoa
he shot your dad yeah not fatally in the
shoulder bad though
oh [__] I was wondering about that yeah
about the illness thing yeah backup went
from inside the house
you know dare to show his mum and dad
total wiper
pharmacy
now that should be your documentary
inside it's like a torture room
[Music]
oh no I'd been abducting people keeping
them down there and doing God knows
what's in them for weeks at a time with
Mom and Dad right upstairs the honeymoon
couple
and the rest of them the rest
pale horses how many are we talking
about eight all been tortured and the
rest of them dark six things really
extreme stuff
but you're dead he his injuries weren't
that bad he was in hospital for a couple
of weeks right but while he was in there
he got MRSA and that killed him over
time oh so he did die for a minute
can we go see where it happened
whatever the technology element comes
where's that old camcorder we can do
some of that can we get in there no
cause why would you want to get in there
because this is what our film should be
about exactly yeah bring the Taurus back
we can pitch to production companies who
will fund it I had a meeting with cases
are at historic I think she might go for
that people already know the story I
didn't I mean it's not who done it
there's no mystery that doesn't matter
dude the Mr
awful it is irresistible sounds tacky no
no no no no no no we won't let it be
you're being insensitive to your
boyfriend's background
you just got here
you don't want to make it I will yeah
he died
now you want it glorify him so much [__]
for Mom she lost her husband okay okay
and we can make that point
her point that would sell even more
really open up the trauma with the whole
family this is my mom's curiosity box I
call it a morbidly obsessive collection
man he looks creepy whoa
four days since Dawn and Simon chalice
were last seen alive in the tourist hot
spot of Loch Henry the holiday Cottage
they'd rented left eerily abandoned I
feel so real yeah this was real the
local area still no sign of the missing
couple that all seems quite odd and thus
Stewart's dad
especially because she's hot I hope
she's okay
I guess she was with us who cares
I love that we're watching a a montage
about editing yeah that's the horror yes
someone spent so much time combing
coverage to make this Montage uh can we
just go back to the part where you
getting attention
this season feels so better yeah
dangerous of making a true crime
documentary on Netflix
from stream Berry I can see you're very
busy that's
that's Stuart
Church boy
she's had no idea this whole time yes
we're doing a documentary about what
happened you'll explain what he did to
your father only if you want us to I
want you to people should know
retribution yeah if he and Adair was
still alive I'd ring his neck myself
with these hands I would get the camera
out
save this energy
if there's anything you want me to help
with
yeah yes yes yes what an interesting
juxtaposition between the other dad and
her yeah
been years since I was in front of any
kind of camera at all
last time would have been that old one
year dad had
but your dad never had
he wasn't a professional
in a day I mean I'd heard of him but
he's not as well known as a Ted Bundy or
a Fred West
if we take this anywhere oh for Network
whatever is going to ask is what's the
hook calendar years on stream Berry too
his dad was one of the victims he was a
policeman he was shot at the farm so he
was murdered he died later of his
injuries come on make it sound like it
can you get hold of any new material
diaries that kind of thing what about
the house itself the dungeon it's still
there and you have access to that yes
so are all the episodes this season from
stream Perry so kind of like I guess
maybe I mean like more meta it also
encompassed previous episodes so maybe
they're just all yeah
I'll get a light up
is that your stage blood mix that is
still in the bag this is lemon juice oh
what's that for shows up on the black
light like piss and uh
just drip a wee bit down here oh like a
day of jazz 12s letting someone's throat
foreign
[Music]
there's a way to incorporate the Eggman
in this documentary though that that you
can sell to the top the hook if you've
never been on a death dungeon before no
I find it quite relaxing I might be a
tourist draw in itself actually exactly
people would go make it an Airbnb
he'll take your pants behind your back
slow down no slow down
look at the road
it's not a plausible King oh no
yeah
come on guys killing it you're lately
still concussed so we have to keep you
in for observation be on the safe side
she knows her stuff look at her she's a
doctor
broke Stewart You're the lucky one
though
no wanking for me for a month at least
you can throw that cutting around and
tug yourself into a coma
yeah yeah I guess so
you rest up I know right I care he's the
only one who's really
it's gotten the worst of this whole
experience
seem to eat here
sleep so fast
thank you
what's about to happen do you have a
prediction I feel like it'll have
something to do with telling the main
guy's dad's story but then the other
guy's dad is going to be something like
horrible they don't want to get out or
something like that like maybe he was
involved or something or
Mr Kane I really haven't a clue where
any of this is going nope
you have to stop your film
why who's the mom really is she the girl
no that wouldn't make any sense mom's
the killer I think I've always known
noon what is she gonna poison her maybe
maybe the mom recorded stuff herself on
these cameras sure yeah yeah I bet oh no
this is so scary what is happening yeah
oh
she was involved
no no no oh I just got like severe
nipples just ah oh this is so bad oh no
of course she wanted to tell the story
she
he was in
[Music]
wisdom
the mistress he's gonna have fun with
the both
of them she said it's been a while since
I've been in front of a camera
oh wow oh the dad was just trying to
protect
it sounds like he still did kill her
though
wow
[Music]
shepherd's pie
it's ready I'll plate up climb out of
window you can't drive back at this hour
The Mask that's right I saw the mask on
the wall earlier yeah oh boy okay
fun together seems like that man got
just so Disturbed that he probably
eventually was like I just got a kill
yeah we just need any way out into the
bathroom
no signal I wouldn't try to call
I wouldn't try to call
just act like everything's normal a
little walk clear my head are you sure
everything's all right I'm fine really
oh I won't be a minute
no no no no no no no no
it's a better go back upstairs than
outside maybe the crash gave you a shot
it'll catch cold out here you're fine
you should get in no
get in the car
whoa
oh man I would have gone upstairs
you seem like you were fine just hiding
there
God you need that evidence though like
oh this is so dangerous
oh this is so bad it's just like they
said at the beginning take a wrong turn
get swept off down a river
she doesn't even have the tape on her
damn it it's so frustrating because yeah
she can wipe everything
mementos
[Laughter]
no no
yeah that's more than eight
I think she's confessing
oh yeah she's ending it wow
oh
man your film's gonna be so big it's
gonna be huge
there's your piano cue
yeah
good catch at the beginning dude the
Taurus hotspot of lock Henry
and so he was in front of any kind of
camera at all wow
[Music]
local officer Kenneth McArdle and his
wife Janet Ricardo's shot the adair's
dead deliberately wounding himself to
cover up his role in the slaughter sure
wow killed herself after leaving
recordings of the murders where her son
would find them
what a gift
sweet oh geez but your dad never had all
this stuff he wasn't filming for
broadcast no he wasn't can you imagine
truth will out and so to honor this
year's documentaries please welcome
Kirsty the 4K screens yep look Henry
will out
[Applause]
thriving tourist tree
project Junipero and the bafta goes to
lock Henry
oh this is the Black Mirror I know yep
them Awards
oh poor guy how awful I am
Worthy
star historic ugh shun him out
the red
[Music]
cup all the masks ugh
wow
cursive thing
Wowie
this is what happens when you want to
become a filmmaker
[Laughter]
can't do anything for the story terrible
things all around
Wowie
oh that was a thick boy
that was awesome that was pretty good
that was awesome that was the Black
Mirror I sort of missed yeah it wasn't
like super technologically heavy
like but there's still a commentary
about our obsession with
True Crime and uncovering the secrets
that was fun yeah that was fun
especially with um like Netflix it was
so
this is the most like Netflix aware
season yeah so far two episodes in is
like
it's like literally Netflix is holding a
Black Mirror to itself yeah so really
it's really interesting what they're
doing here
um seriously to be tethered by the
streamberry element and now I'm like are
all these gonna be from stream Berry
because that's neat
it is and also stream Berry is different
from Netflix in this universe which adds
a layer of strangeness
but they've got the check dumb but but
it's the same but they name check
Netflix in this episode which which just
further like it is but it's also like
calling attention to its artifice it's
so strange and I mean see what you're
saying Steward name checked it yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um and two I mean yeah this is one of
those things where I'm like geez I mean
uh how many of your producers on some of
your own true crime shows have said
things like these and put people in
Davis mcardle's position
I mean not that I guess you know you
have quite an extreme set of
circumstances but still yeah I mean this
this definitely had that like you know
gut
twisting sort of punch that I associate
with Black Mirror like I like the first
episode and it certainly had that like
Edge to it but it is like a bouncy or
happier sort of resolve whereas this
yeah is like the spiral opens up and
then it just goes steadily down into the
abyss from there it was like a wound
this Davis guy did not want to open and
then sure enough has he climbed further
down into that hole and like that I love
the tragic irony at the end of
everything happened that you would
expect to happen the tourists came in
the glorification of The Masks as well
um people want an experience through
crime stuff and like maybe go to the
house and all that this documentary
becoming huge but at what costs yeah you
know your entire soul and and what's
left of your your whole life like yeah
it's great he was eight when this all
happened so it's like his whole life has
now been
outed and and turned inside out and then
to pose that question what's the hook I
think because it's Black Mirror you
trust that
there's something that's going to happen
right like there's some other thing
that's good because I was enjoying I was
really really enjoying it um from
beginning to end I thought the acting
was
like supreme Supreme acting here
um from everyone everyone and the amount
of great misleads that they did with the
father and the mother I'm not talking
about Kenny I'm talking about the guy
from The Mummy and The Last of Us
opening you know his name you just you
name checked him the second he showed up
John
oh sorry John Hannah yeah yeah sorry
John Hannah he's only in that like one
prologue so I was like wait Last of Us
yeah yeah okay mommy but mommy
well that was the thing is all I could
see in my mind is I was the the main guy
and I was like no wait I don't know his
name but then yeah then I was like oh
the one guy in this episode I recognized
it took me a second to get back to it
whatever so
um with John Hannah and the and the mom
because
the the flip Roo there where you're like
John Hannah is involved in it in some
way yeah and the mom is a victim in this
and then they have like fascinating
choices that happen where the mom
decides to be on camera and her motive
seems to expose to get retribution for
what happened to the dad yeah and it
makes sense why she would feel that way
yeah it's really really smart it's
really clever because what they did give
us was a story about like it did it on
so many levels about like a a story
about making the True Crime documentary
some of the artifice into making a true
crime documentary
um The Depths he will go to and is this
worth making you know yeah especially
with you know a day and age where we
love True Crime like we love it so much
and we love dramatizations of True Crime
serial killers and like Netflix just had
Dahmer which was a massive show
and and followed by tons of
conversations about how it portrays the
lives of the victims and all sorts of
stuff and I love a lot of their I love a
lot of like Netflix's true crime series
I think they're they're very very
engaging needless to say uh but there is
always that icky part of me that's going
I mean a lot of times you can feel in a
true crime documentary like the the
purpose of of telling I mean a lot of
times it's just like fun to watch yeah
as a viewer a lot of times I'm just like
this is just fun yeah that's a geek show
yeah you want to see the dirty details
and the the horrific you know things
that you couldn't believe otherwise yeah
uh I I thought that the way they handled
like as they did so much in here as a
commentary but they kept it very
character driven from beginning to end
in a way that was filled with surprises
and you just kept feeling like there's
something else coming but I don't know
what but the just the Journey of making
the film like they they made one of
those it was one of those episodes or
like one of those movies which is like
the fun of making a film at the same
time like there was that sense of wonder
to putting together this this
documentary that could be pivotal uh and
I so I thought that was exciting and
they sold it so much to the point where
I was like the sweaters look so real
like yeah is this based on a true story
that we don't know about it you know
like I I really had to question it
um so on a technical side too I thought
they just really did an excellent job
yeah but yeah and even like the choice
with the mom coming around at the end I
thought was uniquely done you know
because she's still she I loved her
performance because
as a psychotic of a woman that she is
she also has so much love in her yes she
absolutely loves her son and her family
towards the dad yeah and looked upon uh
those Polaroids with Nostalgia and like
oh the good old days I miss those times
and almost as if when she died it was
like I'll be reunited yes there's
nothing left to preserve here there's
nothing of my old life yeah let me
descend to hell and be with my baby and
torture and torture forever it's like
she died when he he died yeah like
blames is it is a really is a really my
it's a mind Bender of it and
um but yeah like
is it's cool yeah I'm just so more used
to Black Mirror being like a more of a
like a crazy technological thingamajig
yeah and it's not really about that but
it is a commentary on our association
with media
yeah just a technology part of it you
know I've only really seen one kind of
qualifying quote in regards to this
season from Charlie Brooker and he did
kind of Express a wish to expand or just
kind of instead of coming up with like
ah what what is the Black Mirror episode
need to have just kind of redefining
what that is and I think here there is a
roundabout technological quality in the
sense of like yes you have
you know the old camcorder and stuff
rooting you to a time and place you have
a drone and whatever but you also have
physical media lasting as an archive in
a time where there's so much Newfound
debate about media that doesn't become
physical at all and that can be kind of
hyper-controlled due to digitization and
stuff like that and so even though
that's not the point like yeah like it
seems like the the main thing it's
trying to address is still like a
societal phenomenon heavily tied to
technology so it it is yeah more much
more roundabout but I do think of all
the topics for Black Mirror to take on
if it's gonna Drift from Tech
specifically I think this does make a
lot of sense because two I mean there's
so much True Crime that centers around
that idea of like oh it was you know the
the happy you know uh all appearances
you know very you know kind of above
board couple you know just sort of your
quaint little couple that had this
really Grim dark secret and so I I like
the way it juxtaposed starting it out
with this uh Ian Adair figure and the
more you hear about him you're just like
oh yeah of course this guy is deranged
and capable of all this stuff and uh and
yeah like there's there's something
about
you know the the ethics of making these
true crime documentaries is obviously on
display in this episode and uh and there
are times where I would imagine that
these Endeavors have gotten it wrong and
perhaps incriminated the wrong people or
bolstered the stories of you know people
who were secretly involved and managed
to conceal that or whatever
um so yeah I thought this spun an
interesting picture because it is partly
about them being exploitative but also
like them being exploitative and
pursuing this project does ultimately
uncover this greater truth and then that
kind of took me out of the time and
place and and more toward the now moment
where like this guy is a cop and she is
you know like a well-meaning lady who
lives in the country these are the kinds
of people that you just assume are going
to be well adjusted or you would assume
would never be involved in something
like that and I think now especially you
know we're finding that uh you know a
lot of the people on the higher rungs of
the societal ladder and who do appear
very you know just sort of again above
board quaint and Etc might be actually
pretty depraved underneath yeah it's
interesting yeah so many influencers you
sure that's where it all comes back to
so many torture dungeons
but yeah the acting was great too I
can't get the acting like the acting was
really sold me it felt like I was
watching a Scottish film yeah everybody
was really just like so natural and like
great at listening and and two like even
though we were sitting there yelling
like you know go upstairs or just like
play it chill like like every little
turn felt I I could feel the
authenticity of each choice even if I
didn't always like agree with the action
or something like that
yeah I mean I don't really know I think
it's easy to be
hear and be logical uh but when you're
you're stranded in a you're in a very
you're so isolated and you're trapped in
this person's home and you know the
roads are dangerous and even though
there was dialogue about that they
demonstrated that with the car crash
what finally makes it real yeah you know
so it is they do establish dangerous to
me on the road
and I was like I don't blame her for not
thinking straight yeah you know of
course I'd be like yeah grab the tape
get out of there hide wait till morning
uh
what or just play cool yeah but you also
don't know like maybe she's trapping me
here and she's going to kill me tonight
you know yeah when you you said the
thing about the poison I was like I
don't know maybe yeah I could see it
happening and that's great because
because then they play on you and I love
the way that the the mom character
ultimately kind of realized like she she
so isn't on that wavelength of she knows
of Pia knows anything at all that it
really takes until they're out in the
middle of the road like it does seem
like she really is just concerned until
Pia like Freaks and runs off and then
she's like oh oh yes okay yeah yeah
there's nothing I can do about this well
she said that she would she wouldn't
hurt her and I actually kind of believed
her yeah yeah like it's so and it and it
begs this
I mean it begs this fascinating sympathy
for a Despicable a character who has
done these horrifically despicable
things gotta be careful about the words
here but there was that interesting
moment where there was
a
activity in the bedroom that you could
hear that you cut to and you see the
mom's reaction to it
and there's parts of this that remind me
of like uh X sure like she's like Pearl
in that movie yeah a little bit yeah you
know like even hearing her son and you
think it's like
disproving of this kind of behavior yeah
when really it is
yeah like oh I want that again yeah
that's an interesting flip Yeah well
yeah and and two it plays on that small
town thing of like oh well I guess you
know yeah sure it's possible you're
isolated you know there's not a heck of
a lot to do already like sure you'll get
into some kind of weird love club or
something like that
yeah that's disgusting that was cool
yeah that was really well done really
icky and ineffective I love that one
that was a great one yeah that was great
agreed poor Eggman
never gonna have a story told I feel
like that episode tops like the last
four
yeah yeah I think this is definitely one
of it's fun like in some ways the first
episode appears like it's like that's a
black mirror but this felt like as much
as this isn't so much about like modern
tech this felt like the feeling of Black
Mirror I don't know I like these kind of
I mean we've reacted to a movie here
called I see you I just watched missing
um I like I love these kind of like
twists and Mysteries yeah and all that
and that are character driven at the
same time yeah these I really love these
kind of
uh genres Styles I think they're really
great yeah alrighty well that's it for
Black Mirror episode two
um it's good to have like this this
brought back the feeling of it's good to
have Black Mirror back yeah that brought
it back for me
um leave your thoughts down below and
this is the one without any famous
people other than Jonathan Moscow what's
his name John Hannah John Hannah yeah I
I thought the woman who played the mom I
think like is in a lot of like High
Caliber dramatic work and stuff like
that like I know I've seen her I can't
conjure her name to mine but uh not that
famous
I feel like she was like just nominated
for something but yeah I mean not as not
as famous as John Hannah
Salma Hayek and yeah Sir Michael Sarah
certainly not or Blanchette sure or
Jesse Pinkman Jesse
I'm just gonna credit him as just
alrighty guys well thanks for being here
let's send this to the
Tyler Hague we all know that we can't be
fooled by your pleasantries you're full
of [__] Tyler hey Tyler you come across
like oh yeah I'm just so
[Music]
but you know what's going on on those
monitors you're keeping tabs on your
caged victims I know exactly what you're
doing in that moment in time torture
Hague you're just going there and you're
eating their body parts you sick son of
a big gross man and then wearing their
skin as hats but part of me is hoping
that that is what allows you to be you
know remaining pledged is that you're
taking their money and shuffling into
your bank account so as long as you just
keep those activities you're doing in
Wisconsin
got no issues just don't bring into
California we got enough of them uh but
if you just keep it in Wisconsin your
neck of the woods much easier to get
away with it out there no one cares it
keeps things excited so thank you Tyler
for not murdering anyone California
um I hope that you never get caught uh
but if our patreon gets shut down uh no
refunds no refunds for to anyone that
you've captured and if you do get caught
we get to react to your story first your
footage and all that stuff all the
evidence we get to leak it and get all
those tasty views and then we you know
who could play you in in a dramatized
movie you know who could play Tyler
Hague let's hear it who's you casting
who's your fan cast
Jonah Hill Shona Hill he's gonna win
that Oscar finally
all he's got to do is go you know to the
real depths of Despair and depravity
everyone needs their one hour photo
movie that's gonna be everyone needs
their their deranged killer movie
thanks Tyler
[Music]